[Music]
there's a cat who got really sick and
tired of paying a huge amount of money
for medical bills for things that you
know when there's an actual like when
you say a cat you don't mean like feline
cat homo sapien you're crazy thank you
you guys don't know how to talk yet
please he's a [ __ ] jazz musician come
on you're cool
no hey there's a cat right
it's good
you guys get it
i should get one of those hats off like
one of those like what the [ __ ] is it
called i think you could pull it off
here but it's like you know it's like
that oh a doctor there's no bill yeah
that's sick yeah sick you should get a
zoot suit i'll probably get a dude suit
yeah i gotta get a bunch of yogurt
outfit first we all should get zoot
suits huh yeah we're down after
balenciaga outfits yeah balenciaga first
oh and then and then yeah
it's expansive yes
but then there's the investment though
you're wearing your wealth it's really
smart okay so
uh
just one cat he's uh yeah okay so this
guy he he got a 60 000
um bill for just getting an x-ray that's
[ __ ] so he's like you know what [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i'm gonna build up x-ray
machine 60 000 for x-ray
60 000 for an x-ray
yeah
i just get insurance i think
yeah probably right
but then that means still that's the
solution the premium you still got to
pay like 10 grand or something dude 60
thousand dollars well it wasn't that
wasn't the only part of it right there
was a bunch of so he went getting
scanned every part of his body
so he went he went to the hospital and
like part of his visit required x-rays
and yeah he got a 69 210 invoice that's
pretty funny
but then nice
boys nice
so then he says that um because
of their health insurance he only has to
pay like 2500 but this experience made
him go well wait couldn't i build a
[ __ ] x-ray machine because a lot of
these extra machines they're just
sitting there right and then because the
hospital purchased them
like for the full amount we all get paid
like a certain amount of that full
amount be like because
it's just chilling there and it cost a
lot of money to get there right
they could just make a photo booth x-ray
machine
it's generally
smart that's not what he did two fur
okay but he built his own right using a
400 using a 400
60 000 volt power supply
he got a 155 x-ray vacuum tube that he
removed from a discarded dental x-ray
head multiple geiger counters and a
giant roll of lead sheet metal and then
he made a video of him i can't play it
obviously because of all the [ __ ]
with youtube stuff but
uh he constructs a functional machine
with minimal risk of radiation poisoning
or electrocution minimal risk wow yeah i
was going to say that because don't you
need like uh
those [ __ ] lead vests and you don't
get yourself he's got the lead sheet
right
yeah
like a lead thing to protect his nuts
from getting zapped don't you even need
a permit to like
mess with this stuff because it's really
yeah you need to be uh what does it call
like a radio tech right it's a free
market nowadays radiologists radioactive
man radiologist former employee radio
shack
yeah that's correct i should need a
radio
radio shackologist if you don't watch
the show to get critical information
you're an
idiot so yeah he he
through trial and error he builds he
like jerry rigged this
uh x-ray machine and it works that's
pretty tight
but he still had to
pay a lot of money for it well yeah but
his his idea was to showcase how
barbaric our healthcare system is that
like you know
they [ __ ] nickel and dime me like
that
and then they're [ __ ] us i do like
that he's able to get an x-ray and then
now he's like
i don't know what's wrong though
what if i need the doctor
it's a nice
it's a nice rib cage but i don't know
is that where the pancreas is what
happens it's gonna turn out he needed an
mri
ct scan he spends all that time and
money building the x-ray machine but he
doesn't solve his health issue yeah like
it's a tissue issue tissue issue you
just post it i'm ready like hey ready
what do you think what do you think's
wrong with my hand yeah
right or quora probably quora quora but
you gotta pay to play on that you gotta
play the play yeah dude you have to like
is that the like uh health internet
questions just general questions about
anything what about webmd don't they
have doctors commenting and [ __ ] oh dude
what don't you just submit your own
x-ray webmd this is my x-ray what's
wrong with you what's wrong it's like
covet 19 probably
if doctors like anything it's webmd yeah
my sister's a vet and people will web md
[ __ ] and like tell her about like hey
maybe you don't have to do all this
because i saw him webmd and she's just
like oh my god those people always think
like oh i'm gonna help the doctor out
like i did my own research let me tell
you have you guys ever seen a virtual
doctor because you don't have those apps
now oh yeah oh yeah so taika had like a
a seizure scare like a month ago and
then we needed checkups but then we
didn't know what was going on so i
thought we need to get so we need to see
someone now but it was like after hours
so we found one of those apps and so we
were able to get like a doctor to come
on the facetime i'm awesome it's crazy
and this [ __ ] was this [ __ ] was
[ __ ] falling asleep while she was
talking
oh what yeah so these are the symptoms
that we've been seeing she's like really
okay
so is that how the seizure looked like
um
yeah
was it more like this
or was it more like
it wasn't like
watch for 10 minutes and then tell me
watch for 10 minutes yeah or was it more
like play a gentle sound in 10 minutes
so that i can
cause it more like i wish you screen
recorded that [ __ ] just made a social
post that's [ __ ] funny she's like let
me turn on my fan real quick and she's
like oh yeah okay was it like this
she put the next fella
did she put some webinar that said make
money while you sleep it's just not a
genius idea passive income passive
income baby she's the expert yeah she's
like we have to figure out exactly how
the seizure looked
and then at the end of the call she's
like you need a specialist
you're like oh yeah oh my god dude i'm
like all right thank you you need you we
[ __ ] know that
you should go see an awake doctor
i'm a sleep doctor because it's a sleep
specialist oh that's good sleep
demonstrator i'm not really a doctor
i've been demonstrated my dad my dad has
done x-rays for that his whole life and
he constantly [ __ ] with patients all
the time he's a radio shack yeah he's a
radio shackologist so he's just he he's
like but he's filipino and the hospital
he works at all my uncles are the staff
so they just constantly [ __ ] with
everybody they're controlling like a
comedy hospital
how do you [ __ ] with them no like he'll
so like someone will come in and like
the days where i would be there too he
they're just like watch this like it'll
be a guy who comes in with some i don't
know something's wrong with him they'll
do the x-ray and then they'll just like
come up to him and they'll just
say yeah it looks like um
yeah judging by this you're gonna have
to get circumcised
that's solid that's that that's
hilarious
we're gonna have to take the whole arm
off the whole arm's gonna have to come
off i'm like oh it's for my leg
they'll just constantly just say all
these shits to everybody they'll do it
to me and my friends too does it make
them feel does it make the patient feel
better it actually does it like brings
more light to it it's like light-hearted
yeah it is they're like you ready for
your sex change now
that's a good one it's a really good one
yeah they should constantly do that [ __ ]
but then they also do extra [ __ ] up
things too when i was uh i do community
service different category i did do
community service at this hospital uh
well not at this hospital i had to do it
at any hospital so i was like okay let
me do it here where my dad and my uncles
work because it'll probably be really
fun but they were like just me like
hazing me oh like
they go hey take this chart to this
patient and just have them sign it okay
cool they're all like why are they all
[ __ ] snickering okay i go in there
it's a [ __ ] dead motorcycle victim oh
my gosh
they're all laughing they're like
because you got a signature
hospital people have such a different
level of humor because they see death
every [ __ ] day yeah it's dark [ __ ]
so for them it's like
and they lowkey have to make jokes about
it so they don't go [ __ ] crazy that
makes sense making jokes about death is
never okay dude never sorry you should
take it seriously what about the
families what about the family families
are all cracking up too that was a good
joke
family's got like their [ __ ] grandpa
like laying on a table to eating sushi
off of them
holy [ __ ]
we always wanted to do this the sushi's
fresher than the guy we're eating off of
he's like like best thing he didn't like
sushi
he hated it he was
alive have you guys ever been to a i
feel like this is more your guys's kind
of field have you guys ever been to a
party where somebody was carted out and
there was sushi on top
really yeah what was it like it was
interesting did you eat from it i did
because i uh it's kind of like when i
was at a i was at a
uh this concert recently i was telling
you guys about outside and there was a
mosh pit and i was like i gotta go in
real quick yeah just check it out let's
do it let's do what to say i did it yeah
but it was really weird did you get the
piece off his dick
what was between the ass cheeks what
they put in there but a chick can have a
dick so yeah so that's a good question
that's a great question
chicks can't have this i'm such a sushi
snob that i always judge it i'm just
like
that's not sushi and i walk away
i'm like anything i was like how dare
you use the hamburgers that's not sushi
he goes to hero jeans and sushi he's
like that's not [ __ ] sushi is don't
people say that it's kind of overrated
dude my mom was cracking up so i was
like once when we saw that documentary i
was like mom you know jiro he has a
[ __ ] spot in the train station and
she goes yeah everyone knows them and
i'm like well you don't sound excited
like let's go book a place she goes
there's way better [ __ ] spots than
him and i'm like what do you mean he
goes
the new [ __ ] is his son
that's where you got to go and it's just
his body naked apparently
[Laughter]
your restaurant's too old school man we
got to spice it up apparently everyone
there
they're always trying to find a new
stuff because it's like why would you
want traditional it's like you grew up
with it you're bored of it yeah so then
everyone wants the new school stuff it's
just foreigners coming in and saying i
want the old stuff
like more traditional and they already
have traditional boring um and not the
best of the best apparently it's just
very hyped up from you know but i mean
it's all subjective you know there's no
truth to it but my mom was like yeah if
you want to go you got to go to his
son's place he's doing some cottage
cutting edge stuff and then you got to
go all these new guys who's like mixing
french [ __ ] and it's so funny because
like the locals there
are like always trying to see like oh
this guy went to europe and he developed
this technique and he brought it back
and then everybody outside are like no
we have to stay pure we got to get the
traditional [ __ ] it's pretty funny
[Music]
you